Moment lahmlegen wird und das ist aus
unserer Sicht was die EVG bezogen auf
die Bahn macht völlig überzogen unnötig
und unverhältnismäßig wir haben die EVG
mehrfach aufgefordert unmittelbar wieder
an den Verhandlungstisch zurückzukehren
und das ist auch gut und richtig so was
jetzt passiert ist total unverständlich
weil die EVG gleichzeitig sagt dass Sie
nicht bereit sind nächsten vier Wochen
zu verhandeln also zu sagen ich mache am
Montag einen kompletten Streik in der
Bundesrepublik und bin dann erst in vier
Wochen wieder bereit zu sprechen das
kann nicht ernst der Gewerkschaft sein
wir fordern die EVG auf unverzüglich an
den verhandlungssitz zurückzukehren und
mit uns zu Lösungen suchen dort sind
auch Lösungen möglich die EVG kann sich
gerne auch im Beispiel bei Verdi nehmen
die streiken auch am Montag sind aber
von Montag bis Mittwoch mit dem
öffentlichen Dienst verabredet zu
verhandeln ganz unmittelbar und hier zu
fordern wir auch die EVG auf
wir sind überall und zu jeder Zeit
verhandlungsbereit und nach gemeinsamen
Lösungen zu suchen und diese auch am
Verhandlungstisch zu finden nur dort
sind auch Lösungen möglich wir haben ein
Angebot vorgelegt was in den ersten 12
Monaten ein Umfang von 11%
Lohnsteigerung hat und ein dauerhaftes
Angebot von 5%. wir sind der EVG
entgegengekommen bei einem Bahn
Mindestlohn von 13 Euro wir haben auch
gesagt wir sind verhandlungsbereit zu
Angleichungen noch unterschiedlicher
Löhne und Gehälter also dort auf
zentrale Elemente der EVG eingegangen
wir erwarten dass die EVG an den
Verhandlungstisch zurückkehrt und wird
dort unmittelbar zu Lösung finden es
kann nicht ernst der Gewerkschaft sein
jetzt vier Wochen lang nicht verhandeln
zu wollen aber flächendeckend
zu leben vielleicht noch ein kurzes Wort
zu den Beeinträchtigungen wir gehen
davon aus dass am Montag wie gesagt das
Land lahmgelegt ist und das so gut wie
nichts mehr im Eisenbahnverkehr möglich
ist also diejenigen die es möglich
machen können sollten umdisponieren und
selbstverständlich sind wir auch wie
üblich zu solchen Situationen in sehr
großen Umfangs bereit wir werden sobald
wie möglich hierzu weitere Informationen
an sie geben
schönen Dank bis hierhin
bei der Situation ist kaum davon
auszugehen dass man das ausgleichen kann
also insofern jeder der umdisponieren
kann sollte dies auch tatsächlich tun
entscheidend ist dass die EVG an den
verhandlungssitz zurückkehrt und dort
werden Lösungen gefunden und da kann ich
nur noch mals dazu auffordern
appellieren und eben nicht diesen
unnötigen und auch unverhältnismäßigen
Streik vom Zaum zu bringen
aus unserer Sicht ist der Streik unnötig
und auch unverhältnismäßig weil wir sind
verhandlungsbereich wir haben der
zentrale Elemente der evg-forderungen an
unserem Angebot vorgesehen und auf dem
aufbauend geht es jetzt darum zu
sprechen und dann auch möglichst rasch
tragfähige Lösungen zu finden
gut einen schönen Dank schönen Tag noch